kerestem egy csoportot a facebookon
például van olyan hogy nárcisztikusok
túlélők csoportja 18000 taggal és
beiratkoztam és volt az egyik hölgynek
amúgy túl túlnyomó többségében az
áldozatok hölgyek igen és és túlnyomó
többségben a nárcisztikusok azok
általában férfiak de azt hiszem hogy a
8020 meg a megoszlás
az egyik hölgy egy nagyon frappáns
mondatot írt azt mondta hogy nektek
nincs az az érzésetek minthogyha mind
ugyan azzal a pasival járnánk vagy mind
ugyanarról a személyről lenne szó mint
hogyha eg nagy hm lennénk ahol ahol
ugyanaz a személy és ez ez persze vicces
kacaktak az emberek rajta de nagyon
elgondolkoztam ezen a mondaton mert mert
tényleg annyira a jellenvonásokat meg
lehet nevezni mintaszerűen megismétlődik
prediktív lehet lehet előre jósolni
szinte hogy hogyan fog viselkedni valaki
hogy hogy szinte olyan min matematikai
képlet
[Zene]